Nói Mình một tháng 12.000 năm, thông tin từ công an tình đồng này đơn vị đang tạm sữa hình sự đối tụi
hỏng thành công, hai mi thuật. Cuế sạy lâu, tình ra lai, sống lăng tham để đưa trà làm só hình
vĩ dưới cứ tại sản. Theo hồ sơ công an, công là đối tụi nghỉnh mà tủy, không có nghỉ nghiệp. Để có tình
tư sai, chương nghiệp mùi tháng 12.000 năm, cũng đã nãy sình ý định cứ tại sản xem
mại của Vì trả xe ôm để bạn lấy tình tư sai. Thì đến ấp tắm, xa lông thành đồng này, công thêm ông
hát, năm 15, quyết tình tin ra, làm đi trả xe ôm, cho đến xa xun đường, với giá một trong hả đồng.
Trong qua trình dí chuyển, công đã đều nạn nhân đi vòng quan nhiều đại đường ít người
quá lại để thực hiện hành đi phạm tổ. Thì đến đại đường bán ở hút công nghiệp lột ăn bị xương,
xa lông thành công nói ông hát dừng xe để đi vệ xin. Thì tại xe vừa dừng xe,
công đã lấy hút khi thu sắn, tình công ông hát, làm nạn nhân tử vong tại chỗ.
Sau khi về ăn, công đã khúc xe mại, một chức vì bên trong có nhiều dễ tự tự thân và dễ trứng hiện đang ký xe,
và lần chúng trên đi vả sát xun đường, đồng này. Qua đấu tranh, cô khai nhận,
chiếc xe khức được mạng đi bán được bún trự đồng, trả nội tình thu vêm.
Hịt, buồn, tức được đu chá, làm nó.